I don't really know what this thing is
other than a really beat up up
looking teddy bear I mean look at this
thing why would you not want this
what's up GQ I'm Aaron Paul and these
are my 10 Essentials
my favorite prop that I own from
Breaking Bad this pink teddy bear was
introduced in the first episode of the
second season it kind of just kind of
popped up throughout the entire second
season and it quickly became my favorite
prop that I wanted to steal they
wouldn't let me steal it but Vince
Gilligan our fearless leader of the show
knew that this was my favorite one and
when we wrap the Series Vince surprised
me with this
This Charming little guy once I got my
eye on this pink teddy bear in the
second season I realized that I was
gonna try to steal a lot of from
that show I won't talk about what I
stole because I don't want Sony and AMC
to know that I have it
sorry
a pair of car keys why they're essential
is this car I actually picked up on my
very first date with my wife Lauren you
know we met at a music festival we had
our first kiss on a ferris wheel you
know I started telling her that night
that I was gonna marry her one day I was
obsessed
I hit her up and asked her if she wanted
to meet me in Vegas for a dinner and a
show keep it innocent and then the next
day pick up a car and uh drive it back
and so we went had the best night of our
Lives we won 16 Grand at the blackjack
table we then jumped into a cab told the
cab driver to take us to the nearest
Chapel to get married you know you think
you're in Vegas it's Saturday night it's
not too late you think these chapels are
always open but we try to open up the
doors and the doors are locked we
decided maybe this was uh not in the
cards for us that night
anyways these car keys sort of represent
our first aid and the love that we have
for each other we just celebrated our 10
years of marriage to be super cheesy I
just decided to see if I could get a
right personalized plate for the car the
first thing I I typed in was I love you
and that was available that just shows
you the world that we're living in like
I just I can't believe that that was a
available so if you see a little blue
Cobra driving around with the license
plate that says I love you now it's true
foreign
okay so this next essential item is
actually a pair of meteorites and so it
starts with this one this was a gift
from my wife we're always looking up in
the Stars you know we would just open up
a bottle of wine and talk for hours
while just staring up at the universe
anyways one of my roommates at the time
he was convinced that 2012 was the end
because he was convinced that well at
the end of the Mayan calendar we're
gonna die I'm like you were out of your
mind and so I decided to make him start
believing that meteorites were slamming
into our backyard in North Hollywood and
it started with this one I had dug like
a little crater and I put this inside of
it and I put a bunch of dirt around the
crater so it looked like you know it
caused like an impact very Amateur hour
by the way and he's like what is this
and he pulls it out and he's like I
knew it this is a meteorite
these things are hitting the ground I'm
telling you the world is ending and it's
gonna this is how it's gonna end I'm
like oh my God it's working like way
better than I had anticipated I had to
level up you know I had to go to the
meteorite shop in Santa Monica I spent
way too much money on this thing cut two
just you know like a couple weeks later
I dig a giant crater I come up with this
contraption that made a very loud noise
in the backyard he comes running out out
of his bedroom and his boxers he then of
course starts losing his mind again he's
like I told you to his girlfriend they
start getting in an argument cut two I'm
not joking cut two about a week later
I'm watching a Giants football game it
goes to the local news there was footage
in my backyard that was shot by my
buddy's girlfriend she brought it to the
news and she claimed it happened in her
backyard and it made the six o'clock
news and the 11 o'clock news fake news
people
fake news
[Music]
Okay so this next essential item uh was
a gift from my wife it's from Tom York
who's the singer of Radiohead and the
reason why she gave me this is I did a
fundraiser for her non-profit called
kind campaign that coincided with the
finale of Breaking Bad I wanted to do an
event for the the public so they could
be invited and watch the series finale
with the entire cast and crew and we did
that and we raised about 1.6 million
dollars for kind campaigning kind
campaign you know my wife started years
and years and years ago she travels the
country who talks to young girls about
the effects of bullying within their
school hallways so she wanted to present
me with something that she knew I would
really love and so she Tracked Down Tom
he wrote some of the lyrics to one of my
favorite songs Fake Plastic Trees and
turn it into like a little art piece and
then at the top it says this is
especially for Aaron and a cost a
million dollars
1.6 million dollars to uh be precise but
who's counting
this is a bracelet that my daughter
actually just made me for Father's Day
she's five years old and when she sits
down she really sits down and focuses on
things that she wants to sort of
accomplish and she just loves her mommy
and daddy and her brothers so much she
constantly makes me things colors me
things she's just such a talented young
lady and I'm obsessed with her story I
love you baby thank you please keep
making me bracelets
okay um oh to keep it in the theme of
children this essential is the very
first toy I bought my daughter after she
was born she instantly fell in love with
it it was constantly in her mouth we
kind of nicknamed her bubbles because
she just constantly was bubbling
drooling on this thing definitely a lot
of miles but is now on my bookshelf in
our little Library this is a beautiful
reminder you know my wife married me
thinking I did not want to have kids I
realized that after playing a father on
a series out of New York it was the
first time I allowed myself to kind of
be in that headspace of becoming a dad
it just sort of changed my mind and I
remember sitting Lauren down I finally
told her that I wanted to have kids and
she didn't think she heard me right and
she wanted me to repeat myself and so I
did and then she just started crying
anyways this is a beautiful reminder of
how PM that I changed my mind
sorry is it getting too heavy in here
now we'll get into the lighter things
bring out the booze
foreign
[Music]
this is bottle one from our very first
batch batch one it's a company that my
friend Brian Cranston and I started it
it sort of represents the relationship
that Brian and I uh have he quickly
became one of my closest friends in the
world when I started shooting breaking
bad he became my mentor I have just
learned so much from this man on screen
and off I just love the man I mean he's
my son's Godfather we're very very close
and when we were trying to figure out
the name for the company we just
couldn't beat dos Hombres it's just
simple two guys you know we're Blue
Collar background both him and I grew up
with really no money in our pockets it's
about kind of two guys showing up going
to work to be honest we haven't made a
single penny off of this company we only
Hemorrhage money into the company
we know how to do business people
um but
we're very proud of what we're doing so
um if you like Mezcal drink some
books I think it's very important for
people to read I think it feeds the soul
these three books were written from one
of my favorite authors who also happens
to be one of my best friends in the
world Jedediah Jenkins this first book
is called to shake the sleeping self he
decided that he wanted to ride a bike
from the Oregon coast to the tip of
Patagonia and he did it in a year and a
half he started at the exact spot that
his parents ended their Journey Across
America he is a proud beautiful gay man
that when he started this journey he
didn't really know or understand his
sort of place in life because he grew up
in a very religious household and his
mother just was not having it leads me
to his third book that is just about two
this book is also amazing but I'm just
now starting this book it's not out yet
but it follows a journey between him and
his mother Across America in a car
trying to see if they can survive their
own differences and I just started it
and it's just so beautiful I'm just so
proud of this guy so I had to bring it
my Leica Q2 I would not consider myself
a photographer by any means I'm not
pretending to be one but I needed a nice
camera once I started having babies this
thing comes with me uh everywhere that
my kids are I'm obsessed with them and
also encourages me to print out photos I
don't like having things just kind of
live on my phone or in the cloud I like
to take photos and try to print out as
many as possible I do autofocus you know
there you go oh my God I missed you
there you go perfect yeah it's great and
it just makes you look like you know
what you're doing
yeah
this next essential item is a candle I
burn too many candles there's candles
burning and pretty much every room of my
house I travel with candles I always
travel with candles and music it's just
a must for me typically it is a diptyque
and so I always go in there and come out
with an embarrassing amount of bags my
wife she makes fun of me constantly but
[Music]
all right G Cube that's it thank you so
much for watching
foreign